first I want to add the original
repository as a remote to my clone so
I'll copy the URL here then I'll run git
remote add I'll name the remote upstream
and I'll paste in the URL I just copied
now I'll check out the master branch and
bring it up to date with the original
repository by running git pull upstream
master when I run git log I can see that
the Chocolate spring color changes here
now I'll check out the stop drop and
roll branch again and I'll merge it with
the master branch by running git merge
master stop drop roll I'll resolve the
merge conflict by adding my stop drop
and roll option alongside the chocolate
sprinkler option and then I'll get rid
of the special lines and to the other
versions of the file next I'll add the
fire and commit to complete the merge
finally I'll run git push origin stop
drop roll to push this branch to my fork
note that you'll need to push this to
origin which is your fork and not
upstream which is the original
repository since you don't have
permission to push to the original
repository since I also want master on
my fork to be up-to-date also check out
the master branch and push that as well
now it looks like my pull request is
good to be merged